next game against tadic
from norway 2 73 so once again
amazed how many
very strong scandinavian
players
are active here
yes i often played this variation
in black and mostly stood a little
well but see if i know
anything here without something
so in black games a
main problem was always that the piece of the
route to get to the six
i try to
send the knight on the journey right here
so now the question is where c5 is exciting
the fifth possibility
i put the bishop in here first
and  do like they used to do
as well
maybe all three don't want to play
just club yet
the brutal possibility for black is
of course
55 but g5 and throwing everything forward tries
to stand against four and
plans to bring the knight but b35
so black is doing here now
definitely serious
not a big choice so that is of course
also a standard plan for the kind
position
however i am already very much
here in there so that i would be
amazed who i was if it were
easy to do but
it is certainly quite as
dangerous  so over the way
and now a jumper here a
cement
so jumps c6
covers the first of course
very complicated statement two is of
course always as good as gone
is practically gone
well I try to
get further challenged here
jumper little
ids spinner the
552  of course watch out at the moment only
covered by the king
would certainly prefer the sound to f1
at the moment
but is something going right here?
he has it because here he attacks again
somehow I still have 40
gymnastics clubs
and jumpers f4 under certain circumstances
in that direction I had now
less expected ok yes it is not but not
somehow implausible
attacks the stop what if
i take b7 just then
goes there we a yes
i don't know yet or so
good at the b 5
extraordinarily difficult positions
i don't know springer r4 i
actually like it  also somehow
hit knight 44 and hit c5
i got 45 god oh god what a
sausage position
extraordinarily difficult to keep track of
an idea we still have if he pulls
away the bishops
g6 of course also depends i had now
thought of a 5 with the dvd 5 and  then
the construction of the tower but
I can also take that and
make her five and now the runner the
five is
very long spees
so I have a nice one that falls on the
three for the knight
runner the fifth red is still like that
and that is now  here the dream falls
thinks f2 covers everything everything pawns
and it's still a spit
we offer to
introduce simplifications
purely materially the position is
already very good
3 yes
okay it's the last
the last straw
but i have all the pieces think themselves
at the moment  mutually basically can
only try to come after five
but there I have the two at the end
yes
besides I think okay
that also attacks the g4 by the way
that should actually be the end of the
attack
yes and also the game yes that was  super
and clear difficult to say
totally difficult no idea how it was there
everything was
possible